what's this
The Legend of Zelda Majora's Mask for
the 3ds now I was really excited to play
this game because I'm a humungous Legend
of Zelda fan I mean please I just have
to show off the shirt look at this this
is a Temple of Doom Legend of Zelda
crossover can you imagine like my face
when I saw it it was just I need it and
since I do get these questions a lot
this was ripped apparel and
unfortunately a one day only shirt
sorry besides the obvious reasons why
I'd be excited to play Majora's Mask on
my 3ds I really did like the Ocarina of
Time 3d version as well and you know
what I'm kind of a humongous fan of the
original game for n64 I mean I have the
complete inbox version right here with
lenticular cover that I won't open
because it's precious and needs to be
protected don't touch it
I'll kill you my point being is I'm a
massive Zelda fan I love the Zelda games
I've played them since the original
Nintendo NES game back in the day I've
been through the highs of Link to the
Past and ocarina of time and the
somewhat lows of Skyward Sword I'm so
pleased to tell you that this version of
Majora's Mask is an absolute high I had
the time of my life playing this game I
had so much fun in fact I was playing it
too much she was getting the point
where's one of those games you're like I
should probably put this down now I
can't what's that dear I have things I
have to do today oh well i have to play
majora's mask for like seven hours now
if you didn't play the n64 original and
don't know the basic premise of the game
a guy named skull kid has stolen
majora's mask it's a mask that you have
to get back also an effed up creepy
looking moon is about to crash into the
ground and you have three days to try to
get everything done that you have to get
done before that happens now when you
start playing the game you're like it's
impossible but as you go along you do
realize that you can use your ocarina
and other instruments to reverse time so
essentially that three-day period really
doesn't have anything to do with beating
the game in that time it's really about
how far you can get in that time because
when that moon is just about to crash
down and you reverse time as long as you
saved it you can keep all the stuff that
you did and all the places you
discovered you lose certain items though
but you keep the major big ones like say
your bow and arrow and the
big thing about the game is the
introduction of wearing masks as link
you put on those masks and you can
actually become different species
whether you're a giant goron or a little
Deku scrub and by changing into these
various things you can access new areas
of the game and have new abilities and
it really makes the game an incredibly
well-rounded experience because you're
not just playing as one singular
character even though you technically
are always linked you get to do a whole
bunch of different things by putting on
these various masks that you obtain when
it comes to Nintendo 3ds games I tend to
turn the 3d off because although
sometimes it's good if you tilt the 3ds
in just the wrong way it becomes
distorted and so you always have to hold
it like exactly in the center which can
get a little tedious in the middle of an
intense battle but with Majora's Mask
the 3d was so stunning that I actually
left it on for quite a bit at the time
so what I usually did with this game was
if I was just wandering around in town
and doing like some random side quests
like finding a stray fairy or something
I would turn the 3d on then cuz I knew I
wasn't gonna be in anything amazingly
intense but if I'm in a temple and I'm
throwing down with a boss I'm going to
turn the 3d off then simply because it's
harder to hold the 3ds like you know
like you're getting all into it and
everything
at least I play games like that a lot of
people tend to complain about the
PlayStation n64 era of games by saying
that those games appear dated well yeah
they do because they came out in the 90s
and graphics have gotten better
that's like saying well the special
effects in that movie from 1982 just
wasn't as good as like the Avengers of
course they're not we've progressed in
technology so certain things appear
better and sometimes progressing in
technology actually make things worse
and attack of the clones compared to
Empire Strikes Back thrown that out
there I can't stand what game critics
say that because it's like well it's its
time period it has some charm to it that
being said the graphics for this look
amazing the backgrounds have a lot more
detail the character animations are more
fluid it all looks great and it's just
so much fun to play as link as well even
though he's a hero that we don't really
know anything about because he never
talks I do think he has serious anger
management issues though because all he
ever says is yeah yeah
a strap I just feel like he's a very
angry person
guys I honestly love this game I had so
much fun playing it I played it too much
actually it was just too much of
majora's mask it reminds me of a time
period where games were a little more
simple and more innocent and you could
actually feel some maturity in this game
too because there were aspects of it
there were more dark than Ocarina of
Time if you haven't played a Zelda game
I strongly recommend playing one and
this could be a good place to start
definitely check this one out guys I'm
gonna give the Legend of Zelda Majora's
Mask a perfect 10 out of 10 also another
great one is a link between worlds this
is actually the sequel to a Link to the
Past the Super Nintendo Zelda game this
one was great as well so guys my
question for you is what is your
favorite Zelda game now if it is ocarina
of time because that tends to be the one
that most people gravitate to what's
your second favorite because just
between you and me I might like majora's
mask a little bit more just a little bit
more guys thank you so much as always
for watching and if you like this you
can click right here and get stuck mine
eyes
you